what would happen if you were to bring a
tiny piece of the sun to earth
short answer you'd die
long answer it depends which piece of
the sun
like most of the matter in the universe
our sun is neither solid liquid or gas
but plasma
plasma is when stuff is so hot that the
nuclei and electrons can separate and
flow around freely which creates a goo
like substance
so you can imagine our sun as an
extremely big spherical ocean a very hot
goo
the deeper you go the denser and weirder
the goo becomes
so let's bring three samples each the
size of a house to our lab here on earth
and see what happens
[Music]
first sample the chromosphere
the chromosphere is the atmosphere of
the sun a layer of sparse gas up to 5000
kilometers deep that's covered in a
forest of plasma spikes that can be
almost as big as earth
it's pretty hot here between six
thousand and twenty thousand degrees
celsius but if we brought a sample of it
to earth we're not really getting our
money's worth
in the area where we take our sample the
chromosphere is over a million times
less dense than air so compared to our
atmosphere at sea level it's basically
the same as bringing the vacuum of space
down to earth
the moment our sample arrives it would
immediately be crushed by earth's
atmospheric pressure and implode
air would rush to fill the vacuum and
use as much energy as 12 kilograms of
tnt in the process
this creates a high pressure shock wave
which shatters glass ruptures eardrums
and maybe some internal organs
if you're standing too close it could
kill you so you'd better keep your
distance
let's go
deeper second sample the photosphere
[Music]
beneath the chromosphere is the glowing
surface of the sun the photosphere which
produces the light we see
it's covered in a grid of a million
hotspots called granules each of them
about as big as the united states and
over 5000 degrees celsius
these granules are the tops of
convective columns churning gas that
brings the heat up from the center of
the sun to its surface
in these columns a few hundred
kilometers down we take our second
plasma sample
it has about the same pressure as our
atmosphere on earth
though still much less dense than air
its heat supports it so it won't implode
our sphere now carries twice as much
energy as much as 25 kilograms of tnt
but this time as heat
for a dazzling instant this plasma would
glow with a million times the brightness
of the sun seen from earth instantly
lighting fires throughout our lab
but a few milliseconds later those fires
are all that's left
the plasma has cooled to harmless gas
floating up from the flaming ruins
what if we go deeper
[Music]
third sample the radiative zone
here the plasma is about 2 million
degrees celsius and so dense and tightly
packed that it creates a sort of maze
for itself
energy in the form of photons tries to
escape but has to wander for hundreds of
thousands of years bouncing endlessly
from particle to particle until it
eventually finds an exit
bringing mata from here to our lab is
what experts call a very bad idea
as soon as it arrives in our lab the
extreme pressure that holds the plasma
tightly together is gone
and the material explodes with the power
of a thermonuclear weapon
our lab as well as the city around it
will be destroyed in an instant
on the bright side there won't be any
radioactive fallout
with our lamp destroyed we can abandon
the illusion that we're trying to do any
science today
what if we go much much deeper
last sample the core
here in the central one percent of the
star we find a third of the sun's mass
the matter here is compressed by the
weight of the entire star above it
in the center of the core the
temperature is 15 million degrees hot
enough to make helium by smashing
together hydrogen powering the sun by
nuclear fusion
in billions of years after the death of
the sun this core will remain as a white
dwarf
if we brought a sample of it to earth it
would cause a lot of inconvenience
the biggest nuclear weapon ever
detonated had an energy of 40 megatons
of tnt or a cube the size of the empire
state building our sample has the
equivalent of 4 000 megatons
this is 4 billion tons of tnt or a cube
1.3 kilometers high
to give you a sense of scale this is the
cube inside manhattan
once the sphere arrives on earth this
super dense matter expands instantly and
creates an explosion with the force of
well the sun
if we get the sample in paris in the
morning the citizens of london would see
what looks like a second sunrise but one
that gets brighter and brighter and
hotter and hotter until london burns to
ashes in a radius of about 300
kilometers around the blast everything
would be burnt
the shock wave would travel around the
earth multiple times
most buildings in central europe would
be flattened eardrums would rupture and
windows break across the continent
the explosion would be apocalyptic
possibly human civilization ending
if humans did survive we could count on
the dust blown into the atmosphere to
create a small ice age so if there is
one tiny bright side it would be that
the explosion might be an effective way
to control human caused climate change
for a few decades
while this is definitely a good thing
all in all we conclude that we should
not try to bring the sun to earth